les allégations d'ingérence chinoises
depuis quelques semaines les accusations
d'ingérons se multiplient avec la Chine
au bon des accusés
un dossier en particulier retient
l'attention l'existence à l'égide postes
de police que Pékin opérerait
clandestine
on s'attendait à ce que plus de
personnes participent à la manifestation
mais les gens ont peur du régime chinois
explique cette activiste ouigo
ces craintes se sont cristallisées avec
la publication d'un rapport d'ONG sur
l'existence d'un réseau international de
postes de police chinois à l'étranger
dont trois qui se trouverait dans le
Grand Toronto Radio-Canada n'a pas été
en mesure de corroborer ses informations
de manière indépendante mais la GRC
enquête présentement sur le dossier
dans plusieurs cas les soi-disant
station de police sont en fait des
résidences privées ou des petits
commerces ou serait basé des
informateurs chinois selon un des
auteurs du rapport
de
intelligence ou le réseau intelligence
parmi les trois postes de police à
légués on trouve ce dépanneur à scorboro
en banlieue de Toronto mais à
l'intérieur on nous a assuré que le
rapport faisait erreur qu'il ne
s'agissait pas d'un poste de police et
que les propriétaires n'avaient aucun
lien avec le régime chinois
les deux autres adresses étaient vides
impossibles donc d'obtenir des
explications dans un courriel
l'ambassade de Chine au Canada ne nie
pas l'existence des trois établissements
mais affirme que l'objectif principal de
ces points de service et d'offrir de
l'aide aux ressortissants chinois à
l'étranger pour renouveler leur permis
de conduire par exemple
est une dissidente connue réfugiée au
Canada depuis une trentaine d'années
l'activiste a fait l'objet de nombreuses
menaces mais l'histoire des postes de
police la particulièrement ébranlée
comme beaucoup d'activistes et il voit
une tentative d'intimidation de Pékin et
s'inquiète pour la prochaine génération
d'opposants comme Jaji Jane c'est la
première fois qu'il accepte d'accorder
une entrevue jusque là il était trop
inquiet pour sa famille qui vit toujours
en Chine
je ne suis pas ici parce que je suis
courageuse je suis ici parce que j'ai
peur confit-il
a décidé de parler c'est pour demander
au Canada de prendre au sérieux la
menace chinoise
cette experte pour sévir le Canada doit
se doter d'une nouvelle loi sur
l'ingérence étrangère on n'a rien
vraiment pour vraiment interrompre les
activités inappropriées qui sont faites
par des individus
ils ne sont qu'à quelques kilomètres de
nous qui voudraient voir le gouvernement
canadien agit rapidement pour fermer les
soi-disant postes de police en l'absence
d'un cadre législatif plus robuste les
dissidents sont condamnés à vivre dans
la peur avec le lourd spectre de la
surveillance qui plane au-dessus de leur
tête ici